the layer heil pen show sponsored by step
finance your go to d5 portfolio manager
on solana luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia highway
plan show it's gonna be another interesting
conversation all about crypto this time um and
we're gonna learn a lot are we in a bear market
i don't know yet so let's find out but before we
jump in this particular um podcast as you know is
sponsored by blockfi you can actually get around
250 dollars when you sign up um and deposit money
with them so i use them and i really enjoy it the
link if you want to join is in the description and
in the comment section so check that out um and
it's also powered by iconplus capital the vc firm
so definitely check them out as well so joining
me today is somebody who kind of just came on the
scene out of nowhere i'm super excited to learn
about him it is cousin crypto josh what's up
what's up thank you for having me yeah it's good
to meet you i feel like we connected a while ago
but i've never been able to know who you are or
learn about you so how are you doing i'm doing
good can't complain you know actually i mean i
can't complain a little bit about the market you
know it's not great um but we'll get there yeah
i'm hoping so so you kind of popped out of nowhere
um that tick tock video came online i don't
think you even had a twitter did you at the time
nope didn't have a twitter um but i saw
my opportunity and i capitalized on that
no that's great yeah so i was just uh you know i
was in college i was at the university at the time
i was at arizona state and i really enjoyed it um
but i just didn't really enjoy the whole school
aspect of it which wasn't great like the academic
aspect um i felt like you know you were kind of in
a system that didn't create a reward creativity
and it just wasn't for me so i was looking for
another way out and i knew going into college it
was not going to be a four-year thing but i didn't
have a back-up plan at the time um so you know
i was doing crypto but obviously you know 2018
2019 that wasn't gonna be that wasn't looking
like a way out so i started doing tick tock and
i said to my friends yo i'm gonna start dieting
i'm gonna lose a bunch of weight and i'm gonna
give out workout advice and i'm gonna pop off
because of it a lot of my friends like laughed
at me like i didn't even have tik tok downloaded
um so i just started doing that you know exactly
that started posting workout advice um dieting
supplements all that good stuff one day someone
asked me you know where do you get your money and
this is when crypto kind of started you know going
off again solana was one of my early trades um and
that started really moving so i just made a video
and at the time i was living in a frat house
so people found that amusing too and i just
made you know shirley's video explaining you know
i'm in crypto i do this i do that that got thrown
up on twitter and immediately i was like okay
well this is getting views i'm going to make
a twitter account real quick pump out a couple
videos we'll see how i do you know go from there
and it really you know just snowballed
kind of just took the momentum from there
yeah i remember everyone was just like who is this
guy why doesn't he have why doesn't have twitter
so you made yourself a twitter account um okay
so you're you were in college um first or second
or third or fourth year where were you so i was a
sophomore i was my first semester sophomore year
what is that second year i mean second year
second yeah so okay so for my second year
okay and why did you i don't understand you said
that you felt there was a disconnect with the
system you felt like university or college
wasn't the way to go talk to me about that
well for example you know in the states um
arizona state and it's not one of the more
expensive universities um without a scholarship
and being out of state it's 50 grand a year which
you know that's a lot of money and so my class
was the first entire year i was a business major
business entrepreneurship which again i feel
like it's a problem because entrepreneurship
is not something you can really teach you
know it's something you're kind of born with
um at least that's my view so i was taking
business entrepreneurship and out of
my six classes i had one business class which was
once a week for 40 minutes and then i had one cis
class which was microsoft excel which was decent
as well um that was for one hour twice a week
the rest of my classes were nothing to do with
business i took gender studies stress management
you took gender studies weight sociology like a
complete random group of stuff wait what is gender
studies i honestly couldn't tell you um i didn't
learn much but you know it's kind of just one of
those classes where you just got to sit there and
you know you're blank and it's over and it's just
like what did i learn so that was kind of my whole
views i was like i'm not paying 50 grand a year
to do this and a lot of kids are okay with it
because growing up you know in the states the
drinking age is 21. and if you have strict parents
who don't let you go out don't let you drink
during high school you only get that freedom when
you get to college so they're okay with you know
pissing away 50 grand a semester because it's the
first time they've had freedom and you know while
partying and everything especially arizona state
being known for it is fun like i wanted to set up
my life you know that's more important for me i'd
rather get myself set up now um and be able to be
financially set when i'm younger you know
i don't want to be 60 years old on the golf
course with my boys like that's i'm already i'm
already old i've already got one foot in the
grave so i want to set myself up now so you know
hopefully early 30s i'm doing that kind of stuff
i just i'm just like gobsmacked at the whole
gender studies thing that's insane because
in england it's not like that like in england
when you do you study something at university
like you study that we don't study anything else
it's crazy and so like what you have here is you
have community college which a lot of kids do do
for the first two years um which i would honestly
if i had it back again it would definitely be
worth it because those first two years yeah
you don't really study your actual major it's
only when you get to your third and fourth year
do they narrow it down and it's just like you
know same thing like i'm like learning like
calculus and stuff which again i've never math has
never been my strong point and even to this day
you know in the industry that i'm in everyone's
like oh bro how do you get the co i don't i still
don't you don't need to know that kind of stuff
in my opinion um you know i've just i've never
really used that stuff in my life um and i just
i couldn't justify paying that amount of money
and then like i said on top of that
it's not like you're learning anything
that you're gonna take into the real world so i
was just like i cannot believe that i'm paying
this amount of money getting this out of it and
on top of it it is taking away four years of your
life and it's four years when you know you're 18
to 22 that's when you got the most energy the most
fire that's when you're gonna be you know the most
productive so i was just like i can't do this and
you know there's plenty of examples of people that
have gone to university become successful people
that are dropped out so for me it's just you know
i'm not like anti-anti-college for some people
they need it they cannot survive on their own they
need to be told what to do when to do it um and
for those people you know go ahead do it um and
you can stay in the rat race you know get a nine
to five but that was another thing i don't like
kissing off so like i don't want to have a boss
that i have to you know this is asked to climb up
the ranks do this do that so i just immediately i
was like when i saw my opportunity i was like i'm
out and i'll never forget the day i was asked uh i
was picked on in class to like speak about our
chapter that we read the night before i hadn't
read the chapter the night before so it was you
know i just came up on screen i was like you know
what this has been great it's been real um i don't
think it's for me though and dropped out right
there and then but like i said like i knew going
into it college was not going to be for me but
i didn't have a backup plan and like that would
be my advice you need to have a backup plan
a lot of people will drop out without a set plan
and that's a problem because you know now you
have no degree you have no direction going
forward um you got to have one or the other
yeah i think loads of people go to university
because they don't know what they want to do
so like there's obviously the partying and the
drinking but it's also a way to procrastinate
adulthood um so so what happened you you dropped
out you obviously had you blown up on on tick
tock because of fitness by that point yeah so
i was just posting um like fitness stuff and
again pretty much in every industry that i've
learned now um you know any industry on the
planet there's a lot of [ __ ] and a lot of lies
to it so with same thing with the fitness industry
um you know i just kept it real from the start
and i didn't [ __ ] you know in crypto how you
have people promoting you know [ __ ] coins
or you know undisclosed promos um the fitness
industry you have people that will take anabolic
steroids say that they're natural athletes then
promote a protein or pre-workout say that this is
you know i take this and this is why i look like x
um and then people go out and buy that and
that's you know scamming so you know i just
kept it real same thing with fitness um started
popping off on there but the money the money was
decent but not nearly enough to like drop out
of school again if i was dropping out i want to
make sure that i'm set up at least for the next
five to ten years because i don't have a degree
you know i don't have a business so if [ __ ]
hits the fan i need to be okay um and fitness was
it just it wasn't enough money um but then you
know when crypto and everything started going
off um at the same time it was kind of just both
of them merged together and i was like all right
well now i have tick-tock i have fitness if that
doesn't work i have crypto um it's kind of enough
for me to just pull out um and even like the
fitness like i stopped for a little just like
just because tick tock is the worst platform
for me personally um i don't know what the
thief is with me it's just oh it's any video that
i post so like if i post a shirt on this video
which was like my thing it now gets taken down for
minor safety even though i'm 21 years old um yeah
a lot of them you know it's just like it'll get
flagged or it'll get shadow banned if you're a new
creator looking to start out i mean tick tock can
really change your life it did it changed mine in
a matter of months um i mean within one month like
i had 10 000 followers the next month i had 30. i
remember i got banned at 30 000 followers and i
almost gave up i was like damn i just put in so
much work like i'm done with this thank goodness
i didn't because again you know all this crypto
and stuff i would have been i would have been fine
without social media but i'm sure as you know like
being an influencer in the crypto space as
well opens up huge doors huge connections um
and you definitely profit a lot more so it's
like tick-tock really just from like posting
like garage workout videos like me just in my
frat house in arizona i just i woke up one day
and i was like i've had enough of this because
i also used to drink quite a bit you know south
african culture it's not it's not something i'm
proud of but you know i did and it obviously
packed on the weight um so i kind of just one day
during quarantine it's really easy to get you know
slip you can go there's a lot of people that
choose the path all right i'm gonna better myself
i'm gonna get healthy i'm gonna get fit but during
a time like cloven and quarantine it's very easy
to go the other way of you know okay i'm just
gonna sit on the couch drink you know all that
and that was kind of the road that i took at first
um and then yeah just one day woke up and like
i always you know people ask me like how i do it
and it's like you gotta want it bad enough like
there was there was a time like i've only just
got back and working out and stuff like the last
month and a half um prior to that like the
last six months i completely stopped because
like i got comfortable with the money and stuff
that i've made in crypto and i thought that was
all that i needed which was just not true like i
watched my mental health slip and everything um
but yeah you know it's been uh it's been crazy the
last few months um and sick talk really just like
that decision one day waking up and especially
at my age like my group of friends tic toc was
something we made fun of um and you know it was
an app that none of us had and it was like a huge
risk for me like personally taking it like
i took a lot of [ __ ] at the beginning um
but again the career that you can build yourself
with it is unbelievable and just you know
i'm living proof i started off with fitness i was
never a bodybuilder before this i never before i
started working out you know over quarantine and
tick tock and stuff i'd worked out maybe like
one two months at a time with my friends in high
school at the gym you know that kind of stuff
never died or anything within a few months like
i was this signed athlete with steel i was their
second highest paying healthy giving out advice
doing all this stuff people were benefiting from
it and i think that was the craziest thing for
me i never in my life like expected to inspire
people or like help people and i just know from
being a fat kid how shitty that is and like losing
weight is the greatest feeling on the planet and
when i had a bunch of you know little kids in my
dms being like yo bro you've essentially like
changed my life like this and that i had a kid
in the gym the other day come up to me and told
me like he was like kind of like shaking he's
like oh bro the reason i started working out and
for me like that's such a cool thing because you
know working out and fitness is something that can
be a part of your life for the rest of your life
and it's going to change you for the positive so
yeah just like a word of advice like if you're
out there and like tired of like doing you know
nine to five and this and that start a tick tock
like it's that it is that easy you know people
like to over complicate that [ __ ] i also i got
my main account taken down um i restarted up a
second one which i don't really post on because
it's flagged and you know emotions get taken
down but i ran up like 150 000 like followers
on that one in a couple months too you know it's
very it's very doable and the crazy part about it
is you can post content that you like and like
content that you're interested so i think that's
what's really cool about it though but yeah that's
amazing i really commend you um for just turning
your life around so many people just play victim
um especially doing quarantine i mean i've i've
see you'll see this as well like i've seen you
know my friends go from university and you know
we're now like in our 20s mid-20s and like they're
not doing anything nobody's doing anything and
they're just wasting away and quarantine and it's
it's so crazy to see so yeah i really commend you
for just creating a life that you love i think
that's amazing not enough people do it they just
um but like so how did you so you how did you
start making money with crypto what did you do
what was the beginning so the very beginning so
i started like i first started looking at this
stuff at like the end of 2016. i was 16 years old
i'm 21 now um and so like 2017 was when i really
started putting money in and obviously like i
got [ __ ] up like i lost a lot of money like
did you buy it i bought like dragon chain um
coin was like one of like my first purchases
um what was that it was when like icos
and stuff were puffing with ian balina
and there was that one that came out i
forget the name it launched on finance
um everyone is talking about how it's going to be
the next big thing same as dragon chain oh disney
partnerships this and that went all in just got
absolutely murked um but then at the same time
i was at the 2017 conference in miami and that's
where i had this friend um one of my dad's close
friends like a family friend of ours um he got
in a crypto real early and he at one point had
the largest mine in north america like a big
ball at this time wow yeah this dude had money
and so he flew from south africa um for the
conference and he knew uh charlie shrimp and
he introduced me to charlie and we went out um and
we had like some drinks and stuff and charlie like
you know you would look at charlie and you'd
think oh like this guy's just a computer dude
he knows how to get on it charlie knows how to
do it so um i had like a lot of fun with them
and charlie actually ended up offering me like
an internship um in florida with him so in 2018
uh when it was my summer because i was still in
high school i flew over there and i interned with
him for a bit that was when um again like icos
and everything with ian balina like had still been
popping off all that that was when i came across
solana and i found it like ico like because i was
that was what i was looking at was icos like i
really wanted to make you know get into those
and so on i came across like i was
like oh this looks this looks wet
and so yeah obviously i was there with charlie and
all them and i got asked them and they were like
oh yeah you know this this does like if it can do
what it promises like this is going to be a hit
and so i obviously could not get pre-sell because
i was and i was like a little kid they weren't
giving me pre-sale so i had to buy it you know
after it launched and everything it obviously that
was like peak bear market and so like for a year
felt like two you know it felt like multiple years
we just went sideways um didn't really make any
money and not that i lost interest but i was like
there's just no point in checking my portfolio
anymore so i just stopped looking at it and i feel
like that's a key that a lot of people miss is
that you do you just gotta put it away buy it buy
[ __ ] that you like you know fundamentally you
believe in it you see it being in a few years
um and you know just put it away and so i did
that and then you know 20 when was it like maybe
like beginning like 2020 or like towards the end
of 2020 was when it really started going um and
again being around from 2017 i was not gonna just
watch my bags come back this time like there's
absolutely no way i was gonna let that happen so
i started making money from crypto around then
um and again i was still my parents at that point
were still paying for me and stuff i was still
you know like a kid um but once i started making
money from crypto which was actually like one
of like the best feelings ever like i could go
like completely independent and like everything
was like mine like i supported me like you know
groceries like it's a small thing but like even
just like going to get groceries and like i can
buy whatever i want and it's all my money um like
that was cool so yeah then that um and then
honestly like a lot of the money that i made
too was just from staking because i've just been
staking my stuff for so long um and then i kind of
just will you know sell my rewards as profit take
that um as passive income and then try and hold
the majority of stuff as long as possible so
like solana obviously i ended up holding like
that was for multiple years um because obviously
when you're holding it you know for over a year
long term capital gains comes into play which is
like you know you're paying half of your tax now
um so that was where when i really started making
the money and then also like from tiktok like the
money that i had made from the fitness industry
just from like protein codes like supplements like
um you know i had a discount code for a clothing
company i took all of that as well and put that
in the crypto um and the majority of it you know
i just i would buy and i'll try and hold it for at
least three months um yeah party was like another
early one that i just bought and hulled for yours
um v change same thing and you know people think
this stuff is easy but it's not like you it's not
you just gotta buy it and it's so simple buy low
hold it you're so high that is all there is to it
but it is so much deeper than that you know you
gotta hold like today's you know days like the
other day where we're down 40 30 it's it's
hard it's not that easy but you have to know
what to buy right and you got the wrong stuff
the first time around you seem to have gotten
the right stuff this time around um you know you
know what you're staking so how do you navigate
everything that there is out there i mean even
i find it so hard to know you know like what is
a good project and what's not so how do you start
so step one that i've actually uh that was kind of
like a hard like pull swallow that took me a while
to understand is and including myself you know um
don't listen to influences influences nine times
out of ten the majority of them are pushing stuff
um you know for their benefits um and there's you
know in my opinion there's a reason there's a lot
of people that are anonymous because they're
doing things you know that people might not
they might not be comfortable doing with putting
their face behind it um so step one would be
you know there's obviously there's the
exception there's those couple influences
that have you know crazy amounts of money hundreds
of millions billions that have been in since
real early and like they don't need to do that
kind of stuff you know they've earned a reputation
that's a little different um so i'd say that's
number one just knock that out the park you get
rid of half of them real quick um number two
for me is the team um because at the end of the
day no matter what the project is no matter what
the idea behind it is the team is the one that's
going to be executing it and so ultimately
like you know you're investing in the idea
but you're investing in a team um if they can't
execute it doesn't matter how good of a project
how sick it is it's just not gonna happen um so
i look at the team and then number three for me
um which i don't feel like i feel like it's been
you know people have looked at it recently but
like hype is a big one like there's a lot of good
projects out there that have solid fundamentals
but they just don't know how to market they
don't spend any money on marketing which is a
huge problem because everyone else is spending
money on marketing um and they kind of just
sit there you know so there's you know there's
plenty of them um i know like for example hbar
is a project that i like but like hasn't really
done anything i haven't heard of them yeah so
it's just like so like a lot of people like think
that they i'm not like too big on it i don't own
any um but so the reason why i don't own any is
because it's all over tik tok and everyone is like
yo like this and that but a lot of people like on
tech talk prefer the technology over blockchain so
i don't know we'll see we'll see how that goes
but yeah there's like there's a lot of projects
out there that have they tick all the boxes but
then when it comes to like social media hype um
all that stuff they don't have it and because they
don't have that their project kind of just like
it sits in the dark you know so it's the same way
back you know apple never marketed if amazon never
might never had any advertisements like it's
the exact same thing and that also scares me
like if i can if i'm looking at that like there's
a 21 year old college dropout and i'm like yo
you dudes need to get your name out there you need
to market and they don't understand that as like
as a project i don't want to put my money there
um and then the last thing that i look at which
again i think a lot of people overlook is they
invest in a lot of [ __ ] that doesn't solve any
problems you know it's just it's out there solving
a problem that doesn't exist it's you know why a
big reason why i invested in solana ethan's [ __
] you know it's it's clogged the fees are crazy um
so that's the main reason i went solana um
was because of that they had a solid team um
the hype at the time too like it was one of
the highest rated icos everyone was trying to
get in on that um and then it was honestly
perfect timing because the bear market hit
everyone was too scared to buy um went sideways
for a bit and then went up so that would be
yeah that would be my last tip is like
make sure what you're investing in
solves a problem if it doesn't solve a problem
there's no use for it you know what i mean
yeah i think you're right as well especially about
marketing um it's so important even just like
on an individual level you know you can see people
out there who are less intelligent than you but
are doing better than you it's because they've
been able to market themselves present themselves
in such a way which is so attractive to people
so yeah marketing is absolutely huge um but given
how the market is right now i'd love your thoughts
are we in a bear market bull market where do you
stand so i get like all the time now especially
like with the way the market is like people will
be commenting on my stuff like yo bro it's a
bear market bull market in my opinion so like
the way i look at it like i don't look at this as
like a monthly thing you know we'll we'll be in
a downtrend for a month people be like oh it's
a bear market confirm bear market like i don't
i'm not looking at that you know i'm looking
at the bigger picture you know we've been in
a clear uptrend now for a while um i still i
don't think we're in a bear market bear market
um because you know when we're talking bear market
it's we don't typically bounce for a couple years
um you know everything's down negative 90
like that's not the case right now you know
you have all these institutions like there's
still a lot of fomo on to talk and stuff
but do you think that's just because the market
has evolved and it's not going to be the same type
of bear market 2018 or do you think it's because
we're just not in a bear market yeah so that was
the other thing is that that's you know that's
the other situation that i potentially see is that
we could be in a bear market but like you say
the markets kind of evolved and it's not going
to be these multi you know year long bear markets
maybe we just you know six months you know trade
sideways downwards action a little bit um you
know then pop back up but for me i'm not 100
sure you know whether we go into a multi-year
bear market or like you say you know markets
have evolved so that's why i always practice buy
five stuff five fundamentals and just hold it
and either way you know you're gonna win in a
couple years from now um so in my opinion i don't
know and i think that people it's also it's so
funny to me like watching all of these people like
be like yeah like you know i'm certain of this
this and that you actually don't have any idea
like what's going on because at the end of the day
tomorrow russia could drop a bomb on ukraine and
it changes everything you know it's so true it's
like it's so funny for me to watch like all this
i'm just like i've kind of like learned now just
like sit back because the outcome is inevitable
so like i said once you've bought your stuff and
you have your coins and you made your decision to
get in there's not really much else to do and all
this extra stress like paying attention all this
it's unnecessary um you know you don't need to
do it because again you are not in control like
control of the stuff and it's the same thing
when i'm not into american football at all but
all my friends are i watch them talk to each
other like they are the coaches and they are
the ones that get to make the decisions on
the field you know oh we should have done
this we should have done that i'm like but
you didn't because you you're not the coach
you can't do anything about it and it's just
like it's it's just as funny for me to watch
and yeah no i totally hear you and you said there
are all you're doing right now is you're holding
your five coins so what are those five coins and
oh i was saying i was saying i was saying fire
coins like solid coins my bad i've got a couple
um i hold so like i'm big on woo network right now
um i know that finance um had i think it was like
20 or 12 million one of those numbers with the two
in it um like a few weeks ago they invested
um so i'm being on that that's an exchange
and i know like a while ago um they were doing
like more volume than coinbase um i know that
wasn't consistent but you know it was it was
there um so we would network i'm big on nftb
um nft platform same thing backed by banan's labs
they were an early investor they're getting into
like the gaming space too which i also think is
going to be huge like and we can talk about that
as well but i think the gaming space in crypto is
really early so you know um seoul i'm still home
yeah i'm still holding some solana um i
did actually take a bunch of profit though
at like 200 which it ended up being like i pretty
much bought the bottom and sold the top which is
crazy because i've never never done that before so
like um you know everyone we talk about doing this
stuff all the time um but very rarely do we do
it so that's been cool but i'm still bag holding
a little bit there um and then yeah i've got i
had some luna which i sold because again i can't
there's just that was you know there's a guy on a
twitter you know wizard he tried to get me in on
that early um and i didn't i didn't listen to him
like four bucks again i thought i put that money
in solana so like can you really be that mad um
that's the other thing like yeah like you know
everyone feels like they've missed out but like
time and time again you know the bald apes punks
solana matic axe infinity it's just shown
that there's endless amounts of life-changing
opportunities um but you need to know about them
right like you need to know you need to be able to
spot them 100 and like any of teens like that's
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on with nft
like people are asking me i'm just like i tried
i bought a bloody pudgy penguin for like five
eighth i'm getting offers for like one eath i'm
done with that so like i bought the top then i
was just like what is this so um i feel like
with the nats too um i think those are gonna
come crashing down so hard like harder than the
meme coins um because i think it's like the same
people that are just recycling them you know
what i mean like going from project to project
eventually like people are going to get tired
and you know you're not going to have i think
nfts you know the technology is the future but
not these profile photos left yes you know these
are just like when you talk about putting um you
know information and stuff like putting paychecks
as nfts and you know having ids as
nfts that for me is the future not
not the not the profile pictures and again like
board ape and stuff a little different crazy
community but like a lot of them i think are going
to crash and burn but i agree you have to you have
to know exactly what you're looking for and again
with influencers be careful because when you know
i see say like for example my boy faze banks like
i'm a big fan of him but whenever he like tweets
about any nft posts it on his instagram anything
the floor goes crazy instantly if you get in after
the floor's gone crazy you know there's not new
people buying that you know you've got to be wary
yeah same thing with the coins gotta know what to
look for yeah no i'm with you on nfts i think that
um it's definitely a bubble there's definitely
um unnecessary hype but the technology and the
concepts in terms of giving something a digital id
or authenticating it onto the blockchain yeah 100
i mean even art like even as even just digital
art i totally see it um but i want to just like
get your thoughts actually on tick tock because
you mentioned meme coins there and meme coins were
definitely the highlight of this bull market for
me um but what was going on on tick tock because
like wasn't tick tock pumping all these coins and
it was kind of driving the market at some point
what happened so again like a lot of a lot of
people don't understand like all these other
which just like it baffles me because all
these people that are doing this stuff are
supposed to be like really intelligent you know
they're supposed to be developers all this stuff
all these people that ended up creating these
random meme coins and stuff do not understand
how this all started and how it all started was
one kid on tiktok made one video about safe moon
and being like yo the tokens burn this and that
that one video got 10 million views why when did
it just the tech talk algorithm and it
was when crypto so that was like you
know when crypto first kind of started going
crazy when we first were heading up to 60k
so that was when you know it kind of started
going mainstream again for the first time in
a while yeah so like the first time it kind of
started going crazy so this dude was like oh
meme coin first one it burns like this and that
and again i'm never i'm not one you know to talk
too much about it but like the iqs on tech talk
are very low so it's these kids that are just
they don't understand market cap anything and they
just hear these numbers and they're like okay bet
they are only putting in two three hundred four
five hundred dollars but when you get 10 million
views on a video if you even get a one percent
conversion rate of that you know it's it's crazy
so this one kid posted that video i mean if he
had played this right you know he would have made
money for his kids kids kids kids kids um i'm sure
he made bread but i don't think you know no one
was expecting it to go the way it did but he ended
up making one or two more follow-up videos and
it just went crazy you then had all these other
meme coins and then you know shiba went next and
a few others but then you had all these other meme
coins trying to just do the exact same thing um
without that viral video and i'm like
that's not how it works you can't just
create the again like and it sucked too like being
half the reason like why like i chilled out with
the influencer stuff for a bit was because i had
like friends and like people that i knew trying
to get me to like promote their stuff and i'm like
no like and that you know like especially any of t
projects bro this one's different like actual this
this that no it's not it's all the same thing and
like you're my boy and it's making me mad because
all the blame will fall on my back you know um
so all these i was like trying to explain that
to people i'm like it's only a matter of time
before your mean coins come crashing down because
also how that works until the second that people
stop buying that the price is going down and the
thing is there's no utility so in order for people
to keep buying that coin you need to have some kid
on tick tock every single month getting 10 million
views on a video the second ad stops happening
your coins are going to [ __ ] and so especially
when i started seeing all these random other coins
coming into the space i gave it a crack with one
or two lost all my money again same thing which
ones but it was this coin like moon moon went to
zero yeah nah i mean it's in the name so again
i didn't put a whole lot of money and i put a
disclaimer out there i was like i'm fully prepared
for this to go to zero and it went to zero people
are still mad but i was like i don't know what
year it's called moon moon and i say that you
know there's a good chance to go to zero so i
don't know what to tell you so i gave it a couple
cracks didn't work out and so i was like you
know i'm done with this but the whole meme coin
thing for me and it's the same thing with nft is
like at the beginning i was like oh you know it's
not really a big deal but like it honestly has to
stop in order for the space to like go forward um
like it's just it's crazy like it gives it just
doesn't give a great look at all you know and
i know we have like the biden administration
supposed to be rolling out some regulations like
real soon so like things like that if we get
shitty regulations it's gonna be because of
meme coins and you know all this random stuff and
i remember posting videos on tech talk being like
do not buy this [ __ ] you know it's it's not real
and there was this one specific dude that created
his own meme coin a tech talker that had no idea
what he was doing he copy and pasted the code said
it he named it scam like like a scam coin and i
was like don't buy this he tried he's like oh let
me send you some i was like no i don't want any
of that yeah i made a video and i was like yo if
you guys buy this stuff you're going to lose all
your money the responses that i got were actually
like incredible like people wanted to take my
head off when i spoke badly about shiba inu
people were livid and they were just like they
were so confident that it was going up and you
know fast forward now it's everyone's like oh
okay like no more meme coins like tik tok like as
a whole has grown up but like six months ago like
they were fully just like oh no it's all good like
meme coins meme coins and it was never going to
end well and you know that's like a lot of people
like oh we didn't have a blow off top we didn't
have a blow off top that could have very well been
the blow off top you know you had these mean coins
going berserk you know like you say the markets
evolved blow off top just might be in a different
form but yeah that was that was absolutely crazy
and that was when tech talk even cracked down like
on like their crypto guidelines and everything yes
i remember for me like you know i know there's no
regulations and stuff on this market yet and you
know you can legally yes you can go and talk about
crypto but i'm wondering to myself especially like
a lot of like the tick tockers and stuff that
got paid to talk about stuff and at rug to zero
surely there's got to be legal consul like surely
somewhere down the line like you have to be held
recountable i don't know like otherwise i think i
think some are but only like only the celebrities
i know that i saw kim kardashian and some
other celebrities are being sued for promoting
eth max is that what it was called yeah well funny
thing about eth max or ethmaxy or something i know
exactly the one you're talking about i saw it on
a story and i was suck but i was at so there's
this uh house in los angeles it's called it's
something house like but so what they do is they
have uh like a bunch of different kids come from
startup companies and they'll do it once a month
and they rotate like a new group of people once a
month and ultimately like you live in this house
together and you all like bounce ideas off of
each other and help each other with your startups
and [ __ ] so like it's cool and i went there
for one of one of their events they won dinner
and i met this dude that was he starts talking
to me and he's like oh like you're in a crypto
like because not many people were crypto there
it was mostly just like business like orientated
so starts talking to me he's like oh like
have you ever promoted coins and i was like no
i really this man he's like oh look i'm the guy
that sets them up i was like what do you mean
like i get talking to her like he doesn't want to
give me his name or anything we get further down
the line and like i'm not shy so i got straight
up asked him i was like dude you're a scammer like
he's like no but like there was this one project
like a therian max that i was in charge of and
like and he pretty much just said yeah that that
he rugged everyone and like this dude doesn't show
his face or anything but he gets like they just
get these telegram group chats he was telling me
get a bunch of people on it um get them to pay
influences they'll pump it and then just rug it
oh my god are you not afraid of going to jail
he's like no not really like you can't track it
this and it was honestly made me live it
i was just standing there and i was like
i want to sock you but i can't do that that is
crazy yeah yeah i know i know my brother was
actually out in l.a like a few months ago and he
was telling me how they were they were creating
these new coins and pumping them to like hundreds
or hundreds of thousands and then just yeah
absolutely every single week like
the amount of people that i have
like on just like in my dms that will fight like
they first found me on tech talk and like they'll
start you know oh bro like love your videos like
they're so funny this and that then a week later
oh bro like i have this nft project like can
you promote it this and that and it's just like
every single one of them if it doesn't rug now
it's gonna happen just because these people cannot
keep up with these unrealistic road maps and
expectations like i don't know if you know about
like the milk boys and like no he's the milk boys
so like they're like a big like uh like youtuber
um um yeah so like they they kind of their main
age group i'd say it's a little bit younger than
me um but they pretty much just launched an
nft project and they they their nft minted
for 0.75 each i believe they sold 10 000 sold out
instantly and they made 23 million off the drop
and so their project what they are saying is
with their utility the whole you know the whole
drive towards it is they're gonna build gyms and
throw festivals this and that there's a shitload
of red flags for one the contract was not verified
which is just bizarre you know it's like okay
so they put out a whole thing like we're gonna
make sure we're doing this right this and that
they announced the release of the nft project and
then the mint would was the very next day so like
there's there was that red flag um there's the
one that they went i watched last night i went and
looked at all the wallets the team was sweeping
the floor which is just you know after the team
initially dumped as it listed um they had sam
pepper and their friends and family which i don't
know if you know but sam pepper he was behind like
save the kids which was a meme coin that rugged
um very well-known scammer in the space um so i
don't know why you know they would have him in
there that's crazy and against yeah so it's like
i'm looking i'm i like the milk boys i'm rooting
for them i'm not saying it's a scam i don't think
you know you can say it's a scam just yet because
they all make all these big promises and stuff
who knows maybe i mean with 23 million dollars you
probably could pull it off but also there's a lot
of questions like to be answered like for example
the majority of their fan base i don't think is
definitely not 21 years old therefore they cannot
go to these music festivals to these clubs that
are going to be 21 and up you know so there's
there's i mean that you have lana rhodes 2 who
dropped her like nft collection which i don't even
know what that is to do with but like everyone is
yeah like it's just like they have same thing as
uh trump's missus i forget her first name but
um what's her name oh wow now that's gone from
my head melania or millennials thank you melania
yeah one of them like i saw that she had like a 99
royalty i don't know if that was real but i was
just like 99 royalty on our nfts and i was like
how is this even a thing and like you have
her like tweeting about like bitcoin and all
this stuff now but she just has some pr dude
like they don't even know what's going on so
it it's for me like this market almost needs like
a little bit of a flush but you know just going
back like i'm same thing like i don't know
if like milk boys like if that project fails
surely they're gonna have to deal with legal
consequences like that's essentially you know
you could look at it that's a 23 million dollar
raise like that is like institutions taking that
kind of money so it's like they've gone and done
that and promised all you know these big things so
we'll see how it happens but yeah the nfts and a
lot of people are asking me right now how hard i
get into them this and that they've been popping
for a little bit now i don't know if i'd be
getting in just yet um again i don't own any apes
or any punks or anything i still believe that we
go through a bear market at least you know like
an nft bear market that's like the time to buy
you know when everyone's when everyone's [ __ ]
themselves no one wants to pick up like it just it
can't go up forever you know just like we've seen
with bitcoin you know what goes up must come down
yeah i'm with you i don't even i'm waiting for a
confirmed bear market before i ape into basically
everything um i'm totally ready for it um but i
want to move on a little bit and talk about el
salvador so i know you have some thoughts there um
so nayeon pickely like he is wild his tweets are
just insane um i read a tweet yesterday and ever
there was like three lines and every line just
shocked me as i kept going and i kept i was like
what am i reading um is he gambling the country's
money i think he's a lunatic because really i
think he's a lunatic because he reminds me of
myself but here's the problem you know i am not
the president of a country um i'm a 21 year old
dropout who's still living near the university um
so it's just like i see the things that he's doing
and one we are like we're no longer early in
my opinion you know when i gave my junior year
of high school which was that is you know sick
almost your last year of high school second or
last year like i was given presentations on
bitcoin and my classes and stuff whenever i
got the opportunity you know to present whatever
we wanted to everyone was looking at me like i was
crazy no one had heard of it that was early you
know now when my uber driver's asking me about it
and stuff like that's no longer early so you have
the president of a nation a not so wealthy nation
that's like loading up on bitcoin that is like
you said like you even like you said it yourself
you're waiting for a confirmed bear market yeah um
he's just like loading up on and i don't know like
the first time he started buying but it got to
have been close to the top um i'm he's definitely
down overall um and you know essentially for me
the way i'm looking at it is he's either gonna be
a hero or he's gonna wipe el salvador off the face
of the earth because i mean what if biden comes in
you know and he drops awful regulations and we do
go down for your two years like can i solve the
door like hang on for you know what i mean so it's
like you have just especially coming from south
africa like i've seen like what these nations look
like you know you can't really afford to just be
holding like you know i'm going to school and
stuff i can afford to put my portfolio away for
two years and just not look at it you know i
feel like the dude has not done as you do like
just doesn't know really like what he's doing
essentially i feel like he's one of us like
he's at the gym like he's just like buying it but
i'm like dog you are the president of a country
at the same time and i hope it works out for him
because that means it works out for me um you know
but do you think he's selling like is he selling
i think didn't they buy around like around like 58
60k maybe they stole but maybe they sold at 68k
i just i don't i don't know i don't know i have
no idea um but i also think too like it's a
little concerning like i thought it was funny
like when you know he gave moody's the middle
finger but yeah also same thing again that's
something that i would do as a college dropout i
don't know if i'd give moody's the middle finger
as the president of a country when they downgrade
me you know because i'm doing i'm doing things
out of the blue um again i'm i'm a very big fan of
going against the grand so respect to him you know
i'm i'm struggling to sleep some nights so i have
no idea how this dude is going to bed um i just
think that you know it's it's the first time
we've ever really seen anything like it happen
and i think a lot of it kind of depends on
what happens a lot of it short term is going
to depend what you know what happens with
biden and these you know these regulations
um and i know the us the second that i'll solve
the door made bitcoin illegal tend to everything
already like you know i forget what they did
but like they weren't [ __ ] with it you know
they were not a fan um so i'm very curious to
see what happens it's kind of like a tick i
think we'll have our answer pretty soon because
again like you know the third world nation you
can't just keep buying the dip and it just not
go up you know it has to go up very shortly um
i do love what they're doing like i watched
like the youtube video on like the little
town um that they took like a few years ago and
everything you know there's on crypto the payments
um they got the one atm there i think that's
dope um and if you could do that you know on
a larger scale that would be cool um again i
think that he could do what he's trying to do
but i would rather wait for a better time you know
like this stuff's not going anywhere soon like
nfts all this stuff i think we're still really
early um again 2.0 hasn't even come out yet i just
think that he could have timed it a little better
you know um yeah same thing i mean it's crazy yeah
because i i just because like i'm sitting here
and like i'm nervous and i'm just like trying to
put myself same thing as michael saylor like he's
got to be an alcoholic at this point like there's
no way that he's just sitting there do you think
he's chill i mean like i think he is but like at
the same like i'm pretty chill most of the time
but also like you always got that thought in the
back of your head and i'm also not buying billions
on leverage so like that's pretty incredible um
you know i i don't think i just think no matter
how good you are at this stuff and i think it's
something that people need to realize like unless
you know you once once you've pulled your initial
like money the money that you need to take
care of yourself until you've done that
it's going to be stressful and i feel like el
salvador certainly hasn't done that you know um
especially like you say if they got in at 58k
i mean if they got in at 50 ak and sold 68
that's absolutely incredible um then you know the
president's a god and he should open up you know
he should open up a cue coin account on my on
my referral link but yeah i don't know you know
um at the same time too ksi went down five
million dollars this year which i thought
was incredible um i considered you know 2021 to be
free money i thought that this was just you know
everyone was making money and when ksi retweeted
that i was like this is you know just to show the
importance of this i hope and i'm i doubt
that he'll do it but i hope that you know
that the president of el salvador will never
get involved with leverage um but you know
that's a scary that's a scary thing to do i
think at least you know the way the president's
going about it just buy and hold the safest way
that you could go about it um but yeah i'm very
interested to see the outcome i think it'll
be interesting for the history books for sure
yeah i mean i'm rooting for them i
really hope it works because i think that
in terms of timing timing it that would just
be impossible we just can't time the market i
mean ideally now would be a great time to sort of
announce that you're going to accept bacon's legal
tender add it to your balance sheet and so on but
like oh country's reserves but i don't know you
just can't time it i'm really rooting for them i
hope you know i hope it does work out um but just
kind of moving forward changing subjects a little
bit um in terms of you your career like what is
the goal then at this point because you don't
want a nine-to-five you don't want a boss you are
ground on socials you're obviously trading well
swing trading so what what's the goal for you so
the goal for me right now is i took a break from
doing like youtube and stuff um i used to just
like vlogs and like funny skits and just like it's
like random stuff um i stopped doing that for a
while um and i'm actually gonna start that back up
this week i'm recording my first video um so i'm
gonna do that and that was like that's honestly
like one of my favorite things to do because it's
kind of just like you know you record you doing
you um and you know you get paid to do so so like
um the plan is to get back on that i really want
to start grinding youtube um and again so many
people like i think that if i can really commit um
you know i get a good editor a good videographer
like i can blow up because it's again it's just
all consistency um and just posting like a lot of
people just don't do it um you just have to do it
so canada's definitely move forward with that um
and then just continue honestly to so what
i've been doing with like especially while
the market's so volatile like a lot of people
are scared but when you get these negative 30
dumps prime example you know woo dumped all the
way to like 49 cents or something i checked this
morning it's already back up to 65 cents so you
know you don't have to time it perfectly but
when some are like my favorite
alts are down like 25 30 percent
i will you know load up with some spot and i'll
just wait for the leaf bounce wait you know 10 15
anywhere there sell it um and then that kind of
keeps me busy because again the whole the hard
part about this you know with the investing is
you just you can't touch it you just buy it you
leave it um it's very boring you know you can't do
anything so like the swing trading kind of keeps
me active a little bit um tech talk i don't know
if we're gonna go forward with that just because
so much drama um and then maybe i don't know we'll
see how far the bodybuilding goes um just you know
i'm curious just like again being like a fat kid
my whole life like it's kind of cool like to be
doing she did it yeah keep it up yeah no 100
it's also kind of just like show people like
you because i mean i was obese like i was uh i was
not in the best shape at all you should i don't
know if i haven't seen but if you put a picture
up on twitter of what you were like before yeah
it was it was it was it was ugly it's somewhere up
there i'll drop i'll drop another one you should
do it again do a before and after have you ever
seen like the michelin man like the dude the dude
that advertised for like for the thai company it
looks like a giant marshmallow that's right i'm
gonna come up really quickly anyway what about the
michelin man how do i spell that oh i have no idea
but he's like a tire like a like a tire guy um one
of them i like that yeah that's how i was looking
oh wow yeah not great um you well that's amazing
you should upload you should upload that i want
to see that no 100 so yeah that's why that's why
i kind of wanted to start youtube again and just
like document it um because people just like you
people don't understand like your mental health
like and physically like that starts everything
um and like you go even deeper into it like talk
about like foods and stuff like the reason
why in my opinion like the ultimate downfall
which like i know a lot of people will get this
but like the ultimate downfall of society is going
to be the food that we're eating um since the
80s male testosterone has dropped one percent
like every single year um you know it's no longer
men 20 years ago look like men versus today you
have these 25 year olds on tik tok that look 16
it's because their testosterone is on the floor
and you know when you've got low testosterone
you're depressed you're lazy um and a lot of
this comes from like the food and [ __ ] that
we're eating today so it's like you know you feel
like [ __ ] you're not going to be able to work
you're not going to be able to make money you're
not going to want to go out you're not going to
have the energy to talk to girls guys whatever
it may be so like i think a lot of people overlook
that but it literally starts from like step one
yeah no you're totally right yeah like my
trading everything like that's why i got back
into the gym you know like a month two months
ago was because like i noticed that i didn't
have as much energy it wasn't you know i wasn't
watching the markets wasn't doing as much research
um and so like i find it crazy that in canada
i saw that maine on twitter tweeted that their
gyms have only just opened up like a week
ago like that to me is insane because gyms
aren't essential business like it cures
depression you know if you're gonna if
you're gonna hand out opioids and all this
and that at the same time like you have to
allow people to go to the gym like that is
my form that is how i go and like you know
it's not that not that i'm depressed but it just
makes you feel good you know like you just like
you ready to move on with your day um and it's
like i just i notice if i don't work out i don't
feel as good like i don't i don't feel like i've
done anything i haven't achieved anything you know
yeah i'm totally with you i think there's so much
wrong society now that's a podcast for another
time um low testosterone the food you know girls
looking like guys guys looking like girls but um
yeah crazy i don't know where we're going again
people like like they rarely worry over this stuff
like yeah for me like i'm not too worried just
because it's again outcomes inevitable i cannot
there's nothing no matter how hard i work for the
rest of my life no matter what position i get to
i'm not going to be able to do anything about this
you know society's going to be society it's going
to do its thing and like i see a lot of people
complaining all the time i'm like yeah if you hate
it that much just move off the grid you know go
live on like a little farm and do your thing then
and then you can live by yourself and you see how
you like it but i think the best thing to do is
just make enough money so that you are independent
and immune from whatever society is going through
and then surround yourself with like-minded
people because there are enough people
who see the world um in a similar way so um yeah
i feel like that number's growing too especially
all the [ __ ] that's going on like oh
yeah i was never so much like yo like
if the system this and that like i'm fully now
like i'm not with it at all like it's just like
after all this [ __ ] like especially me moving
to you know the whole reason i moved here with my
family originally six years ago was the corruption
and all the [ __ ] from south africa africa yeah
and so i was originally i was born in zimbabwe
so like a little further up left zimbabwe because
you know it was going down the toilet south africa
then started going down the toilet came to the us
then realize that see the thing that upsets me
about the us like africa like they're so bad at
hiding their corruption and stuff you know it's
happening like it's blatantly obvious it's right
there in your face so like you're not if it makes
sense like you're not that upset you know you know
it's going to happen so it's like you know the
outcome it's like bet like you know my taxes
are going there whatever the us i've learned has
far more corruption than africa will ever have
the thing is they are just better at hiding
it um which is more painful to me and you know
you don't need any further proof than looking
at all the uh the beautiful democrats and
republicans that outperform the aspy you
know it's absolutely it's incredible so um
that to me was a big eye-opener i was just
like damn you know everywhere is kind of uh
everywhere's got its problems and you kind of just
for me like at least in the u.s i'm safe which is
you know number one priority um south africa is
not that safe of a place johannesburg is like
one of the most violent cities in you know in the
whole world it's crazy um so that was one thing
that i learned but yeah the us very good at hiding
their corruption um and the one thing i really get
in uh rapping and patriotism and i really like
hate like too like how the us it's just uh it's
more everything's become about politics like it's
no longer about the truth at all you know you got
news channels fighting each other like it's
crazy it's you got full grown adults acting
like little kids and it's just like it baffles my
mind i'm just like you know you guys do you well
i really appreciate you coming on um your insight
is really interesting um i loved everything that
you had to say i think you're so on the right
path i think you see the world in the correct
way so i'm super excited to see what you do um you
know in the next in the next few years so where
can people find you and follow you so um you can
find me on twitter at cousin crypto um spot with
zero at the end and then i have a podcast heinous
pumps that i've just started in the last few weeks
me and one of my boys he's another student at
arizona state um so it's pretty cool you know you
get to listen to two kids living during covert and
all this [ __ ] so you know i kind of get to see
it from our eyes um and then instagram josh.bryant
um be posting on youtube too jaybiz athletics
gonna be all over the place uh 2022 is a year
for social media for sure amazing guys definitely
go follow um cousin crypto some amazing insight
there thank you so much for coming on it's been
great to have you thank you so much for having me
i had an awesome time for sure guys don't forget
to subscribe hit the like button and tune in for
another great guest next week we'll see you then